welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast and on this week's episode i was
joined by harry simpson harry has been
on a really interesting journey where
he's worked in recruitment for just over
five years but for the last four and a
bit years he's really progressed and
really kicked on with his recruitment
career at fraser dove they're an exec
search firm they recruit within the life
sciences space and we really break down
why he's being able to build a
successful network how he adds value to
his clients and candidates we broke down
day plans we broke down his mindset
and so much more
enjoy this episode harry welcome to the
podcast yep thank you very much for
having me looking forward to this one i
said to you that a lot of people that
listen to this i sort of sometimes you
realize oh i've interviewed loads of
business owners and haven't sat down
with someone like yourself who
fallen a bit years into their journey
you've progressed quite quickly
and a lot of people
really enjoy learning from people that
they can relate to and on a similar
journey i want to get to
sort of where you are on your journey so
i'm really excited to sort of unpack the
last four and a bit years yeah it's been
a journey of your career so where we
always like to start and i'd be
interested to just get your your take on
this is
just the the question a lot of business
owners think about managers leaders
think about so i'd love to hear your
opinion on like what you believe are the
characteristics and traits that make up
like a highly successful high performing
modern day recruiter
yeah no thank you for having me really
excited to be on the podcast um so for
me there's maybe three or four things
that i think fall within that category
of making a top performing recruiter one
for sure is resilience so i'm sure
you've heard that answer before but you
know naturally the industry has a lot of
ups and downs um and
you're going to face adversity over time
so it's something that is going to come
your way i've had even today alone i've
had a great day i've had some highs
today and i've also had something that's
a bit of a setback so you're always
going to experience it within the role
but it's how you're actually able to
take those setbacks but keep pushing
forward through them
is definitely one that i would say i not
only try to remind myself constantly but
also when i'm actually interviewing
candidates for people that are not only
for the jobs that i'm working on but
potentially people coming in to join the
business that's something that i'm
always looking for for sure another one
is a solutions mindset so
um it's definitely something we talk
about a lot within our company again it
kind of relates to that you're going to
face adversity piece but
um
you're coming up with solutions to
overcome the challenges that you're
facing not maybe just immediately
turning to the person next to you to
just sort of ask for help and sort of
deflect that um
that problem that you're facing onto
someone else and just say you know can
you fix this for me
trying to if i can if someone in my team
is facing a challenge and they come to
me and say i've had this problem
but i think this is the way that i'm
gonna handle it what do you think that
usually for me i'm like okay cool i
think i'll talk to them about it but if
they're coming to me with the solution
then i think that's the kind of behavior
that i i sort of look to encourage for
sure love that so what where where i was
like to start then he was like who wha
who was harry before recruitment
how did you describe harry before yeah
so it's been it has been quite a a
journey for me how many times have
people said that um yeah i uh i've
started out my sort of career journey
started out at the time when
i was i had friends just about going to
university so for me this was probably
about
six years ago or now or so now um and i
remember at the time i knew that
i didn't want to pursue this university
route i kind of had a bit of a view that
it was potentially high cost i think the
prices of university would change at the
time i'm not someone that slates uni
just because i didn't go i think it can
be a great
you know course of development for
people that want to take their career
and the direction or actually just go
and connect
100
but i decided not to go down that route
and i wanted to go and pursue work and
and you know that's testament i think to
also the input from my parents they gave
me that sort of confidence like my dad's
quite an entrepreneurial type so had
that ability to just go for it um but i
think i was lacking motivation around
things like education for i didn't
perform the best i'll put my hands up
and say that um but i always worked hard
outside of you know school and college
so
i knew that it wasn't an effort thing it
was just about finding the right
motivation for me so i've changed a lot
in that sense i've found you know a
passion for what i want to do i've
understood that maybe financially
motivated as well which is a part of it
but also i think really i found a
purpose so
that's been one of the key changes for
me well and a lot of a lot of young
people struggled to find that yeah so
what did you stumble across it they've
been quite organic or was it quite
intense yeah i mean i'm sure you see
this and a lot of people
say this right yeah i've i do feel very
grateful because i think you're
absolutely right i think there's a bit
of a i wouldn't say crisis but there's
definitely a difficulty now with people
in the earlier stages of their career
it's competitive out there and it's
difficult to understand what is it that
people want to do i i got quite
fortunate in both cases
i do believe that you make your own luck
sometimes absolutely we'll see how uh
that's perceived but
yeah the first the first situation is as
i said the day that my friends went to
uni i was like okay this is this is the
future now i've got to go and make this
happen so
i remember i just started calling out to
recruitment companies funnily enough
really yeah i just got straight on the
phone because
which
why i got straight on the phone because
actually this
my parents have always been quite like
that get get yourself they have their
own do they have their own businesses or
um yeah where did my mom came from like
events management my dad has had and ran
his own businesses over time so that's
the sort of entrepreneurial side there's
definitely like a
sales bloodline running through the
family for sure so that's definitely
there but i just i thought
writing up a cv
and sending that to people what sort of
response rate that's what is that going
to get
so weirdly enough it was the first call
i made
when it was the first company i ever
worked for really pulled them up and i
actually was asking about i think it was
like a football like admin assistant
role for a football club or something
like that i was interested in this role
got it all wrong the girl was like no
we're a recruitment company i'm not just
going to tell you who this is with
um it's one of those but i actually
managed to turn it around on that call
to warrant myself an interview with the
company and they did graduate
recruitment so that was my first sort of
step into the industry
and then uh yeah interviewed the next
day started the next week and that's
okay so your first job was a recruitment
job yeah yeah so i was doing graduate
recruitment um and that was
just a purely business development role
so that organization was split up into
business development account management
and the talent generation piece um so
what would a typical day look like for
you then who was you running a prospect
yeah i think it was a really good entry
for me into recruitment because um i
think one thing i also look for now is
quantity with people in terms of what
quantitative work can they do
yeah because i'm a believer that you can
refine someone's skill set and get the
quality out of them
but i always maybe look for quantity in
their
actual inputs now but at the time i was
doing um cold calling dial outs i was
probably doing maybe 150 dial outs a day
to get 60 calls or something in that
sort of range so it was just picking up
the phone
um yeah internships to graduate
recruitment companies and that served me
for a while how long is that for i did
that for
18 months 18 months and i did quite well
i can't measure the worst cold core
experience oh man
i don't know oh there was one where no
there was one where i was almost certain
that they could hear me and that they
would just deliberately ignore me so
you'd pick up
and they'll lie
it's quite humiliating when that happens
you're there like
great this is actually happening right
now you're really putting me through
this so yeah that was one of them but um
that was a good experience but wrong
sort of industry in focus for me um it
was a bit at the lower level of where i
wanted to be at and then fortunately i
was
uh in a pub in my like home town like
one summer day slightly written out of a
story
and i was sat there enjoying like a pint
with my dad and got talking to this guy
sat across from me and he ended up being
a guy called thomas who's now my boss
thomas dove and we introduced uh we got
introduced to each other and i remember
i had a business card at the time that i
thought was quite flash so i was like
take my details let's stay in touch
um and uh
yeah and from there i guess you say rest
is history but he contacted me
about three or four months later saying
that he was looking for a researcher
sure quite like the idea of that because
um what i was able to do was to take the
business development work that i'd
already got but also i wanted to
understand the process of delivering
candidates into
full cycle and yeah so yeah started
there and that was in january of 2019.
so really quickly then and then we'll
unpack the frozen dove sort of career
journey so far
a lot of people are absolutely [ __ ]
scared of cold calling yep
like looking back on that and i'm sure
there's been elements that you still do
a bit of this now or
advice for people that
can help them overcome that cold calling
fear i don't know what like i'm sure you
spoke to people about this before but
like looking back and the experiences
you now have if i'm someone that
i feel like i'm not great at cold
calling or i'm really worried about it
what would your advice be for them yeah
i'm trying to dig back to four years and
what my pitch was at
going all the way back but if i think
about
if i think about now i think it's be be
aware of your presence on the phone with
that person try to be the person at the
other end of the line and try to
understand what their experience is from
your perspective i call it sort of
having this bird's eye view of the
conversation so really get above the
call
you're obviously going into their day
you might be cold calling let's say it's
someone's mobile it might be a candidate
you're going into their day you have no
idea what point the day they're going in
they could be in a meeting
and i think what you want to do is
calmly but confidently
present yourself within probably a 10
second time frame and say this is why
i'm contacting you
appreciate my right now might not be the
right timing but you know is there a
better time to discuss this particular
topic something like that i think that's
quite beneficial if you that's more
candidate driven if you're doing the
business development side i think it
does require a different knack
you've always got to get your
personality across and you've got to win
that sort of like emotional battle with
them a little bit if uh authenticity and
be bringing yourself to the call i think
so um and then there's lots of different
versions of course there's people that
will be calling switchboards and stuff
like that and lots of people have lots
of different styles i'd always just
recommend you know listen to the top
performer within your company and
understand what they do and try and
replicate some of the things that get
them success no no i really like that
bird's eye piece because i think we've
all been hammering where you picked you
pick up a phone
and
they don't they don't appreciate that
that they're interrupting your day and
they just go straight into
their pitch or wherever it may be yeah
and that's what really annoys people
yeah do you know what i mean i think the
best thing that you can do at the
beginning of a call which i actually do
is get permission to carry on with the
conversation or not yeah i mean yeah but
i think it's i really i really like that
it's like let's remember let's actually
appreciate the position they're in look
it from their point of view and
let's just respect that and then i think
that's that should help you get more out
of your conversations rather than just
trying to get everything out yeah short
period of time yeah they call it like
the show up and throw up thing yeah
where you just like give them everything
in 10 seconds and it's like who is this
what are you even talking about so
absolutely yeah i love that so let's
let's unpack the last sort of 400 years
then so
just to frame this up for people so
you're just saying to me before we
started so
in around the towards the end of like
2020 you said you started some sort of
mentoring responsibilities then a bit
more solidly for the last eight months
or so you've been in a role where you've
got some more direct reports like two
soon to be more people and then there's
some more indirect people that you
support and help as well right yeah so
leading up to that was you just
an individual contributor you was very
much just focused on your own
performance and supporting other people
in the team so when you say as a
researcher yeah obviously it off is it
exact search right so
being a researcher was that very
candidate focus and then did you then
sort of go on this journey to then start
trying to bring in your own business
like if you could just frame that up for
us and then we'll then go into some of
the the key parts of that journey yeah
sure so when i moved into that
researcher role i came in at the time
and the business had just won quite a
sizable project so
i think it was maybe 40 rolls or so
within what we call like product
supplies so procurement and supply chain
um for a company based out of the
netherlands
and it was an opportunity for you know
me to get my teeth into the role um at
the roles that i was working
and had a lot of success i probably did
around about 15 placements over that uh
first you know eight month period which
was pretty solid i was i was happy with
that and you always it does also require
a certain environment you know after
that eight month period i think someone
ended up leaving the business and that
presented an opportunity to to give me a
bit of a chance but
i naturally we were already having
discussions about the development into a
consultant role within about a 12-month
time frame so it kind of got fast track
from there um
and the
the next four months i ended up taking
on some existing in-house accounts which
is not something everyone gets i
appreciate that but
um was able to take on some roles based
out of switzerland
you know sort of 20k deals apiece which
are reasonable deals at the time and
that got me to my target for the end of
that first year in the business okay um
and then i remember going into
um i think it would have been 2019
and sort of moving into a bit of an
unknown i didn't really know
how it was going to develop i was
obviously riding a bit of a buzz in the
sense that i'd hit that financial target
and i'd had a good uh first year in
performance
um
and fraser dove has been developing that
whole time so it was in its infancy when
i joined it was about three or four
years old and i've seen it develop quite
a lot since then sure so when i actually
i came in that first year that i had in
in
recruitment i actually ended up being
the top biller for the year
as a first full year as a consultant i
won't go out there and say that it was a
crazy high number i think it was maybe
in the 200 range which is pretty solid
still first year um brand new industry
market you had to get your head around
as well exactly and i won't sit there
and say i won every single piece of
business and it was all mine but there
were some you know key bits of retain
business that i'd won in that that had
contributed to a large part to that
overall number
um
and
the way that i was able to develop was
by ensuring that i was surrounding
myself with people that were achieving
high performance and really just
latching on to some of the traits that
they would have or the way that they
communicated or if i liked a certain
sentence or a way to pitch some kind of
solution then i'd bring that into my own
style i actually found myself like
weirdly copying people a little bit too
much i was like suddenly thinking like
i'm starting to sound like this guy
wait wait but where did that come where
where did that come from for you to make
that decision of like you know what i'm
gonna try and
like even though you could have you
could have had a bit of an ego at that
point right and go well people should be
listening to me and taking things from
what i'm saying yeah because i'm
the top performer in the company so like
where like why did you make that
decision that right okay i'm going to
try and pick up as much as i can from
the people around me and try and make
that my own like where why did you
decide to have that approach i'd say
like so the leaders of the business are
people that are very much are mentors
and i aspire to be they have very
different traits and characteristics but
i take a lot from both of them in terms
of their styles um and
that sort of um that drive that ambition
that across that first year that's what
ultimately helped me get to that point
at that point i
had a good four months leading up to it
but
ultimately
across that year i was just gathering
and i was listening to everything and
just trying to replicate what i saw
other people around me doing
um i think i'm also someone that you
know i do react well under a pressure
situation i think i actually broke my
wrist in march of that year which was
not ideal i mean
i think i was like voice typing emails
into the laptop and stuff which was so
that's so it's a sort of bit of a
setback put me in quite a difficult spot
because i think i got to about april or
may and then i'd done like 30 or 40k so
i was not on the target yeah and i
remember having a conversation with um
one of my bosses and
it was like right now is the time to
really sort of you know go for it you've
got to show us because we understand
you've had this problem don't worry it's
not bad culture but you know i agreed as
well and it was like okay i've got to
show what you can add to the team now
what your value is and i think from that
moment onwards it sparks me on um
and i and i've had a couple of these
like gear changes all throughout my time
at fraser dove where
yeah that next piece just spurs me on to
the next one uh what and what it what do
you feel like it took
you to feel like actually maybe i'm i'm
not maximizing my potential here i don't
know did you have did you feel like you
needed those moments for someone to go
look you're capable of way more like
let's click on yeah
or over time has it actually more come
from within where it's like right now
let's push on these things i think it's
definitely a combination of multiple
factors i think i was aware of after i
had that
really good year and i started to pick
things up i was like okay i've got i've
got a good understanding here and i
could feel
i was having good calls with clients and
i was connecting people and i almost
found my craft in a sense and i was like
i can really enjoy this role and i can
get into it um but you also need the
right backing from leadership and your
mentors to sort of give you the
confidence to say like you're someone
that's got potential to do this but you
know you've got to be able to take on
the constructive criticism in that sense
and not just be like i'm the best this
is going to work out if i keep doing the
same it's just always going to be this
way
always looking to evolve and adapting
the role and so
yeah i finished that year it was great i
was like here we go let's let's do it
again let's improve for the next year
and then that was 20 20. so that was
covid so it was like oh okay different
whole different situation now and
actually
you know putting hands up but that was
actually a time i really just struggled
like in terms of not maybe personally
but from a business perspective i think
a lot of others in terms of like your
performance or like yeah yeah and i
really i'm not a fan of what you
struggle with what do you struggle most
what was it working from home i i really
thrive off of the buzz of being around
people and i i get inspired by hearing
other people doing well in their role
and if i hear positivity or if i hear
someone else doing something great i
want to implement that into my own work
and all of a sudden i was just
completely isolated um
and like
every bit of motivation would have to
come from me and it weirdly it sort of
got me back to a time when i'd maybe
have to be revising for revival yeah
is not fun no and that's obviously i
didn't do particularly well within that
education i did okay but not maybe
didn't push myself as hard and i
it's something that i've got a lot
better at now i'm able to operate quite
well within that space because i know
that i set myself certain goals and
targets that i've got to hit but um that
was a difficult yeah yeah it was a
difficult year i mean i say it was it
was a difficult year for everyone of
course it was from like a billings
perspective it just stayed neutral so i
did the same number or there about so it
wasn't a bad year yeah i think just
because of my competitive nature and
drive to want to succeed i was i was
like that's annoying i could have had a
could have had a great year there but
um that was good hey everyone a real
quick one from me this podcast would not
be possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincerie and sauce breaker
because you listened to this podcast you
were able to get your hands on exclusive
savings on both of these award-winning
products if you're all a growing
recruitment business you have to check
out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with sourcebreaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so all
the way up to that point was you like um
okay so was you doing the client side on
the candidate side was you're doing both
yeah so i would be doing yeah a full 360
role um i'd get some support so let's
say i've got maybe between i don't know
five and eight live roles i'd maybe be
able to pass on
one or two of those to other people who
have joined the business recently and
they're working just purely on that
reservoir yeah yeah exactly so let's
just get a bit granular here what's been
the most effective way that you've found
to like be successful business
development and be successful at
developing those client relationships
you think for me the most successful way
um
is is understanding the value of the
network and understanding the value of
the network that you build and the
people that you keep close to you so if
you were to
say how do you business develop well the
broader answer is you have to do a lot
of a little of everything basically you
have to cover the board so you know
there are speculative introductions
there are dialing out to people making
calls here and there
um i do something where i called like a
compounding network strategy where i
schedule in reminders of course to catch
up with people over certain periods of
time to make sure that i'm staying in in
touch with that close network and that
for me has been the most effective one
compounding network yeah
that's interesting
so obviously you were saying that
basically what i take from that but you
talked me through it is if i do these
things
every single day every single week over
time it's going to compound and and have
a huge impact or to get me to where i
need to exactly yeah and
i
you know i have it where
you know
a relationship should never be
transactional so i've if i'm not gaining
something out of it now that and and i
only see if i only see it that way it's
going to impact me very very negatively
from a bd perspective
because i'm only going to be in the
moment of every single call
i've had relationships where i've had to
catch up with someone every month for 13
14 months and within the last two weeks
something's finally dropped and sure
it's been worth that time and so that's
my that's my networking strategy so i
have regular check-ins and i automate
them so people do this naturally in
recruitment they just have it in their
mind that i need to call this person
i'm not i'm not wired that way
necessarily as well as some people i
don't think and i need the reminders so
i'll either just have it scheduled in my
diary or i actually scheduled the
call-in with them to catch up whether it
be on a monthly bi-monthly quarterly
basis um following a good networking
discussion or talking to people and
yeah i just find that as a really really
key tool and if you just did that it
might work for you to some extent but
it's really about combining
finding what works for you and combining
it with lots of other different business
developments like why so just talk to me
a bit like why why would i give you my
time on a monthly basis
yeah that's a really good question
time on a monthly basis comes from being
able to add value to conversations
i
have again come back to the mentors
leaders of the business
i've always been given the right sort of
message around this networking piece and
something i've been focused on is
becoming a key opinion leader within my
space okay i focus within a very niche
market
and i'm specialised within that area
and would go out to say that i work with
a good percentage of the market or the
people that i'd want to work with within
my space
it is a bit smaller than some of the
other functions across our business but
because of that you know i've got that
sort of inch-wide mild deep knowledge of
the industry
and every time i can connect with people
it's not transactional it's not about
you know how can i help them or you know
are they looking for support and a role
a lot of the time i'm looking to go into
these conversations and add value to
them and and look to share market trends
and if there's an opportunity to discuss
solutions because
particularly within our market within
the life sciences right now we're going
through a very turbulent period there's
a lot of activity there's a lot of
growth we're seeing this across other
industries as well and so these partners
need your solutions they they do need
our support it's it's it is as
straightforward as that but that doesn't
warrant you the work or the opportunity
to work with them you've got to give
them a reason to work or partner with
them and also the reason as you said to
connect with them on a quarterly basis
or bi-monthly whatever it may be um so
making sure that you come to the
conversation
you know giving two pieces of
information and maybe understanding one
piece back or something like that i
don't really go in with that sort of
structure no i mean yeah because i think
that's what people would be thinking
right okay well what like because like
you said i think this is the
like i really i just love the way that
you're talking about being consultative
you're like trying to add value and
you're leading with that and like you
said you're not transactional which i
absolutely absolutely love
so just just find a bit on that because
i think they'll be useful for people
like what what might be like a market
trend that you might share because again
people go okay well like what what does
that even look like is it you're saying
you know like
have you noticed the x company has
recently um got funding i don't know
like what what what might that market
trend look like
there's something
for us that we're aware of so within our
life sciences market which is for people
that might not know it covers
pharmaceuticals biologics medical device
and it's also a funny industry that i
work in called outsourcing which okay um
i won't go into nowadays probably but
for example within the life sciences
industry there are
98 of companies are hiring over the next
five years okay so that's ridiculous
growth
the whole market is hiring so everyone's
hiring for the same talent um i'd love
to say we can help everyone find the the
jobs that they're looking for but it's a
huge market out there of course so one
of the things that i'll always come into
the conversation is you know what is
your employer value proposition and how
do you how are you currently taking your
brand to the market um what is your
talent you know attraction strategy um
is this something that you've considered
what we're seeing in the space is that
you know your competitors are doing xyz
we're also helping potential competitors
do xyz through these solutions i'm
bringing this to your attention because
if you don't get ahead of the curve
you're going to face challenges in the
next you know 3 6 12 months so it's not
and it's just giving them actual real
world examples of what's going on um
which you're just picking up by
being in your niche speaking to people
seeing what people are doing doing the
networking yeah asking the right
questions um and you know i and hearing
things internally you know i hear
someone else say that and i take it with
me i go to the next place and i do a bit
of research on it to you know validate
it i'm also always you know looking into
the market understanding what
acquisitions have taken place etcetera
um so yeah that's mine i love that yeah
because i know because a lot a lot of
people struggle with this of like they
may think that
in order for them to go into that
conversation add value you'd have to be
the life sciences expert or you'd have
to know as much as they do about
outsourcing you get what i'm in and
actually what you're talking about is
well no i don't i'm not talking about
that i'm saying i'm talking like you
said the
um talent strategy the things you're
seeing in other markets everyone's
hiring what you're doing to stand out
how how is your brand perceived in the
market and they're the types of things
that you can bring to their attention
bring it to the table that is is really
valuable yeah um
so
okay so
one thing i had to ask you like i saw it
on your linkedin and this may be more
recent but it says that you actively
speak to like the c-suite and really
senior people right yeah yeah
how have you like
how have you dealt with not feeling like
an imposter in those conversations yeah
because i'm sure i speak i like i've
interviewed a lot of young people and
this seems to be like a really big
roadblock for them i've done a few
sickness where
they would have been studying a couple
of weeks ago and then
after like two three weeks later they're
speaking to a
a ceo or whatever and they're like oh my
god yeah this but like who am i i've got
no credibility to speak to have you had
to deal with that yeah do you know the
timing that i've literally had a call
this morning with a c-suite member a ceo
actually of an organization we've worked
with this business for a long time but
it was a new discussion with someone at
that level and
it comes down to um
you know understanding there's
peer-to-peer communication um
preparation is key you know if you go
into those calls and you expect
everything to go very smoothly um and
without the right preparation or having
the right knowledge about the market or
without your space you you will find
some challenges so i
what i'd imagine maybe some people might
say is you know you can't just go in on
your first week and just think that it's
going to be perfect at the c-suite level
making sure that you're going on with
those calls with people i would say and
sort of pairing up on discussions with
c-suite not always going to get the
chance but let's say it's a a commercial
call
but you're working to potentially
partner with a client or something along
those lines i think being a part of the
conversation with someone else and being
that sponge for the first couple of
weeks or months however long as it takes
that's definitely a good idea because
you can really start to you know
understand the kind of language the
communication the structure of the
conversation um
and and then it does it does come with
time naturally you you know you might
get a little bit nervous going into
these calls i think that's always
natural but you have to understand
people are human and um i think also
you know if you've got the confidence
that you're going into this conversation
knowing that one they're either a
candidate and that they are looking for
an opportunity or that they are a
potential partner or an existing partner
with a real problem
then they need to speak to you um
and uh you know whether you're winning
business or trying to and you're trying
to be the selective partner you know
you've still got a solution something to
present to them
um
and yeah i think just being on the same
level and
treating them with respect yeah okay
yeah 100 interesting so
uh again getting a bit granular here but
like how you said earlier around how you
had some highs today some like lows and
challenges like i'd love to hear your
take at the moment on like how you're
navigating the sort of candidate
landscape and market so speaking to
countless people um recruiters at the
moment where like crazy accountable for
stories they find it really hard to get
people over the line candidates for
support for choice like you just said 98
of your market web is going to be hiring
over the next three to five years so
these people that you're speaking to
building relationships with
must be sport for choice and you must
have a lot of people trying to grab
their attention make them curious enough
to to speak to them how how are you
finding this at the moment and what what
things do you keep top of mind to
make sure that you have more actual
placements actually happen rather than
falling out and having those those rough
days in recruitment that everyone has
yeah it's a really good point
so you have to get as close as you
possibly can to the candidate so you've
got to understand everything about about
their world about what's important to
them
we've had some really interesting
examples one of the downs from today is
maybe going through that experience but
you know you can sort of foresee these
things happening in the market now you
know counter offers are kind of an
expected thing so it's going to be
happening um i've had a really good case
study of it today within my team where
you know by
really tying into you know understanding
um you know what it is this individual
wants from their next career step
understanding their motivations from
very very early on in the process
having complete transparency with
communication around
other offers that might be on the table
you know acknowledging the fact
particularly within this case it was um
you know the offer that we had was lower
than some of the other offers so
financially a lesser offer but we've
managed to close the candidate and that
comes down to
understanding that individual investing
your time in it does require putting in
some extra time or some extra hours you
know maybe taking an out of hours cool
if they're in the us or something like
that but ultimately these are all the
one percent improvements you can make to
give yourself that that
much closer personal tie to the to the
individual and i think right now in this
market and i i know obviously just life
sciences
but i know it'll be the same across
others as well
if everyone's just looking to offer more
money
then nobody's offering anything
different so
you know emphasizing the benefits the
reasons why they wanted to relocate or
move in the first place
and trying to look beyond just the
financial aspect as to
decision making for that candidate
that's going to give you the edge i
think in in this market at the moment i
love that and again it comes back to
that point of not being transactional
right yeah and i think also i think also
you i guess you've got to be honest in
the fact that if you catch on very early
that person you're speaking to is very
much just driven about
finances then be transparent about that
and ask those questions that maybe don't
hear the answer to yeah you've got to
ask the hard questions you know how do
you feel taking accepting an offer
that's going to be financially lower
than what you're what you're receiving
elsewhere and get a real feel feel free
i think you know in this case it was it
was um
it was a good outcome some people are
just going to chase the money but
it will give you a better chance
so
how and then i want to make sure like
before before we finish then so
how have you found a really difficult
period to a lot of recruiters i speak to
they're aspire to be in management
leadership then when they're on that
journey they just find it they find it
really difficult yeah uh how's it been
for you like i know obviously it's been
like a gradual journey where some people
may find themselves going from like not
really managing anyone managing like
four or five people right but how what
are some of the things that maybe you've
had to work on
or changing your approach that you feel
has
made you or is on helping you on the
journey of management and leadership um
so i talked about it earlier it's the
changing of gears for me so it and this
is not just from a um
like a
i'm gonna do i'm gonna have a higher
output or i'm just gonna do more of this
i think you actually have to change your
own personality quite a lot you've got
to change the way that you behave and
interact with your team i think if you
try and continue maybe some of the
previous relationships that you've had
with you know certain colleagues or
whatever and just hope that that will
transition nicely into this next role
that might not work out best for you
like that's something you have to have a
bit of a step up in maturity um i'm also
eight months into the role solidly so uh
yeah if you're looking for sort of
leadership experience advice there's
definitely people out there better
qualified but from my perspective um
you know
not everyone as you said is suited for
that management role i think definitely
be aware of
your leaders
for people that you know working within
organizations
understand that you've got to have the
right sort of guidance and leadership um
and that it's not going to be the right
step if you're just the highest
performer to take that step up into a
management role is it something that you
wanted to go into then would you quite
motivated it was something that i was
definitely open to considering and the
thing that i'm grateful for fraser dove
offering is there's always been this
flexibility to sort of say we're going
to give you this responsibility we'll
see how you take it on but it might not
necessarily be the past let's work it
out and fortunately right now it's going
well um but my management style
is um leadership through high
performance so
i i try not i don't get really involved
in the day-to-day pushing of you know
kpis and really getting down of course
we have kpis within the business and i
encourage the team to get alongside
those
but for me it's about showcasing what
high performance looks like okay having
success in my role and then uh coaching
and mentoring the people around me to
sort of level up and and develop within
their own position so leading by example
exactly yeah um i tried to get away from
that term of like management and more
just sort of leadership yeah i love that
so a couple of things again going going
a bit granular here but people this is
the stuff that people want me to tell
sure what
talk to me about what does
what is a
a typical day plan look like for you in
terms of like talking about how you want
to lead by high performance
so what does like a perfect day look
like for you that you think gives you
the best chance of uh having that high
performance yeah we want details here
yeah no i'll go for it i'll i'll break
it down but a perfect day
they come around sometimes yeah they
they're not always available so i think
that's the first thing just be aware
that not every room
yeah everyone has a perfect day but my
perfect day would be coming in and
on a monday i'll always have an agenda
for the week and i'll always be really
really thorough with my planning so i've
got to know exactly what i've got to do
and ideally the time frames the dates in
which i've got to deliver it by okay so
my let's say i'm middle of the week i'm
looking at my agenda
i'm looking at things that i've got
checked off some of the things that have
also come into my world over the last
couple of days and i'm really
prioritizing what i need to tackle first
um not losing sight of business
development for administrative
activities
um
and really setting out a plan i'd
probably do maybe 20 minutes of planning
every day okay just to make sure that at
the end of the day at the beginning day
yeah i sure probably should be a bit
better at it i should probably make some
notes from the night before i think i'm
always jotting some bits down okay but i
usually come in like 15 minutes before
my official day kicks off get 20 minutes
of of planning down um
then i would do a bit of initial
research looking in the markets my
mornings are usually booked actually
with quite a lot of pre-booked calls so
it might be that i'm doing maybe second
candidate regis for people within my
team
networking calls you know generally sort
of 30 minutes at a time
and i'm also within those gaps i'm doing
market research so what does that mean
i'm looking online onto you know
different websites
news news websites that are specific to
my market and my niche
and sort of gathering an idea of what's
going on within the space and of course
i'm gathering the information from the
people that you know i'm speaking to on
the calls in the morning yeah
um we go through again maybe do a few
administrative tasks might be sending
out some cvs might be calling out to a
few people that we have on the system
checking in with some people in my close
network um takes me up to lunch
um yeah what to have for lunch
sushi today that was good um
uh and then yeah come back around about
one o'clock um and usually the afternoon
is quite busy for me because i i work
globally but i do work i have a heavier
percentage within the u.s or north
american market a bit later um yeah i do
um not
not all the way back it sort of flexes
from day to day so it's not always the
same um but yeah i typically in that
time and then connecting with the u.s
market at eight o'clock their time on
the east coast starting to do a few
pitch calls these are going to be
between 45 minutes to an hour um these
are going to be pitched booked in by
myself but also we call them like
partner pitches where my team have
brought in the leads and i help develop
or business develop them with them is
that where you're pitching the different
solutions that you have yeah so we have
you know we have we
are definitely a business that we grow
and develop our staff a lot of companies
do out there of course
but um you know not everyone's ready to
jump on a pitch and deliver executive
search solutions from the moment that
they move into a search consultant role
so
partner pitching with someone like
myself that has a lot of experience and
understands the the range of solutions
that we can offer i joined them to to
help them in their development um as you
know consultant moving into senior
principal consultant
um
so yeah finishing up the day few
business development activities um i'd
like to do some maybe speculative
introductions to my close network you
know sharing great talent that i've been
speaking to over the course of the week
um
and
yeah usually a few other calls something
gets crazy at the end of the day and
then all of a sudden it's six o'clock i
love it so you may or may not have
picked up on this but i'm speaking to a
lot of recruiters that are really
putting a lot of
resource effort into going to the us
yeah anything that you pick like how
would you describe the opportunity over
there so typically what i hear is
the perception of the recruitment
industry seems to be way better in the
us
placements in terms of fees
higher typically yeah um and then also
it seems like people are just way more
open to being sold to or like these
types of things so how have you found
because it seems like you've operated in
a few different parts of the world how
would you describe the us opportunity
and maybe some of the nuances
yeah
the the market's definitely more alive
you compare the us to somewhere like
germany you've got a two-week notice
period versus a six-month notice period
um you know some places in switzerland
we've seen people with whole 12 months
notice before they can leave the role so
very very different markets when you
look at look to compare them and because
of that there is a bit more of an
openness for for people to move you have
completely different cultures so um yeah
like entirely and even across the us you
get different cultures of course across
different states
um
the u.s market is just a little bit more
active for us you know i get the
obviously just the view of the life
sciences so
we
it's very very candidate driven at the
moment a lot of the people that i work
with are leading manufacturing
facilities that are
making covert vaccines you know we had
one partner makes 600 million valves in
a year type thing and i've got to
identify the individual that's going to
be running that manufacturing facility
that
skill set is very sought after as you
can imagine because everyone's trying to
you know manufacture these vaccines that
have been developed and it's something
that will continue over time
so
when you're working in that kind of
competitive market it's something that's
not only the top of your industry but
actually on you know the news every day
yeah it's the top of the market
it does add a different level of um
yeah of how competitive it is for sure
so
in order to get ahead you do have to be
very very creative that's when your
network you know has to play into your
hands you have to be able to
utilize the people close to you ask for
referrals because a lot of people are
going to be looking for the same talent
and if you're trying to apply the same
solutions or you know trying to apply
the same reach outs you're going to you
know find it hard i love that so as you
come to to the end here then um
obviously i think i told you tonight
that i was going to message
but no i reached out to
uh thomas obviously the one of the the
founders and spoke really
really highly of you and one of the
things that he said that
he absolutely loved about you so i just
wanted to sort of end it towards here
really was he said one of the things i
absolutely love about harry's is his
growth mindset
is that something that you feel like
you've developed got better at having
i've always had because i think if more
and more people listen to this or more
and more people in the industry
had more of a growth mindset
there's just way more chance that
they're going to be able to achieve
their goals and maximize their potential
so
i'll just i'm just interested to get
your thoughts on your journey with that
if that's something that one of your
mentors has really highlighted
yeah i and yeah thank you thomas i
really appreciate that um
i
yeah i think
there's naturally in people that are in
high performance roles you'll find a
natural ability to be able to um start
to develop and it might just be at the
very early stages but have that growth
mindset but in order to fully
you know develop as a consultant in the
world of recruitment um
you've got to be able to give 100 you've
got to absolutely apply yourself to
every situation um you've got to be able
to see the positivity in things you've
got to have that resilience as i
mentioned
you also got to have the right mentors
in place that are going to say
you are capable of this you don't know
it yet but you can actually do that and
i've had that
across my time i remember transitioning
from
yeah like last year alone it was
something like i my target went from 240
to 350. yeah and then oh my god how the
house and then i think i ended up on
like a 550 year of out of and i was like
if i did if i wasn't told if i wasn't
set that bar
then
i i i don't know whether i would have
gone for it i think naturally i'd like
to say i would but you need someone else
going you are capable of this the market
is here if you apply yourself we're
going to give you this resource to
support you in your development then
yeah anything is possible so yeah that's
definitely the way that i sort of see
things harry's been a pleasure cool
thank you thank you very much cheers
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode